[Music]
this week on forward
we imitate really profoundly
interior things like what other people
want from a very young age and that
informs a lot of the decisions that we
make in life from what major we choose
in college to what kind of career we go
into and we usually don't even
understand how that process is playing
out inside of us we're social creatures
and our desires are going to come from
other people real fictional historical
right they don't have to be people on
social media be careful who you make
your enemies because you become like
them and I think this is a there's a
really important lesson to be learned
here in U.S politics it causes us to
miss out on a path forward
[Music]
thank you
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast entrepreneur in Residence at
Catholic University and author of a
phenomenal book wanting the power of
memetic desire in everyday life Luke
Burgess welcome Luke hey Andrew thanks
so much for having me oh your book was a
pleasure to read in part because we have
a lot in common uh so you were an
entrepreneur of a venture-backed company
in Las Vegas essentially where uh you
ran in the same circles as Tony Shea his
company Zappos almost bought your
company I spent a lot of time in Vegas
with Tony as well but this isn't for our
first time meeting did we ever see each
other in person I don't think we did I
think this is it yeah I thought so too I
I thought I'd remember so why the heck
did you want to become an entrepreneur
and I know there was some soul searching
uh down the stretch when you were like
is this really what I want well the
reason I wanted to become an
entrepreneur is really the topic of my
book The Medic desire before I was an
entrepreneur I was an investment banker
I went to NYU I worked on Wall Street I
was on this hyper mimetic track doing
what everybody else wanted to do my life
was totally miserable and
um back in you know
2005 2006 being an entrepreneur wasn't
quite as cool as it is today but I had a
couple of my friends leave Banking and
go start companies in Silicon Valley and
it was me seeing them do that that
inflamed this desire in me it sort of
gave me the courage to leave and then
once I started starting my first couple
of companies I realized that I was also
caught up in this game of imitation
looking to my right and my left and
trying to keep up with what my other
entrepreneur friends were doing and
that's kind of the theme of what I
wanted to write about because I realized
I am imitating people that are modeling
desires to me
all the time without even knowing that
I'm doing it and I finally woke up when
I was 29 years old after having success
as an entrepreneur meeting Tony Shea but
also feeling Whiplash in terms of my
goals and Ambitions were all over the
place and looked looking back in my life
seeing the influence of various models
of Desire on me Tony himself being one
of them you know I'll never forget the
first time that I met Tony I'd had some
success with a company I met Tony was
driving I was driving a pretty nice car
and I met Tony and you know he was just
jeans and t-shirts every day and I
started asking myself well maybe that's
I should be a little bit more like that
because maybe that's what a successful
entrepreneur is like so that when I was
in this funny kind of memetic process
where I didn't have a stable sense of
self yeah so memetic so people
understand it uh it's just uh trying to
imitate others is that correct
it's imitating other people but
imitating them at the level of their
desires so the reason you know we use
the word memetic is that imitation is
something that's a bit more visible
something that we're aware of mimesis or
mimetic desire goes under a surface
level limitation to the very imitation
of interior things like what other
people want so we're imitative creatures
we that's how we learn math it's how we
learn language it's how we learn all
kinds of cultural norms
and many people have known that for a
very long time what Rene Gerard
discovered who is The Thinker that
really inspired my book is that we
imitate really profoundly
interior things like what other people
want from a very young age starting with
their parents starting with maybe our
siblings and her friends and that
informs a lot of the decisions that we
make in life from what major we choose
in college to what kind of career we go
into and we usually don't even
understand how that process is playing
out inside of us your book is largely
about why we want what we want which is
fascinating and I love this diagram you
had of Maslow's hierarchy of needs where
you say look this is way too cut and
dried where the truth is after you get
beyond the basics you have no idea uh
what it is that you want and so you take
endless cues as a kid from your family
but also maybe from advertisements you
talk about how when you were in college
then it all became about banking
consulting which is by the way something
I literally wrote a book about myself I
wrote a book called smart people should
build things and it was about how young
people right now just keep getting
funneled to uh banking Consulting law
and and I wanted them to become
entrepreneurs and then now you're taking
to the next level being like even being
an entrepreneur is just because these
other people did it which by the way a
version of that happened to me where I
met an entrepreneur in my 12 20s when I
was just starting out at the law firm
and then I was like this law I
want to be that guy and then I tried to
be that guy and then my company crashed
and burned uh and then I kept trying to
be an entrepreneur for a period of years
had some success and then create
adventure for America where I guess our
paths intersect where I was like more
people should become entrepreneurs
um because I thought that it was a
harder path to follow and that you could
use some support uh so let's say that
someone here's your thesis and is like
okay so I get that people
pick up their desires from people around
them like so what like isn't that what
we're supposed to do like uh and you you
detail how this actually leads you in uh
some not great directions oh I mean it
can happen in positive ways and negative
ways you can be inspired by a really
positive model of desire for you know
the kind of um Dad or Mom you want to be
or the kind of um you know person you
want to be in in your career you know
honest uh hard worker Integrity but it
can also work in negative ways and I
should just say and clarify I love
entrepreneurship I'm still an
entrepreneur and in fact program yeah
that you know that teaches
entrepreneurship at the high school
level in in several dozen high schools
around the country the difference though
in that program is we need a diversity
of entrepreneurs doing different things
and not having this reductionist uh idea
and definition of what being an
entrepreneur means where you have to
start an app it has to be Tech related I
mean that stuff is good like what who's
actually going to build things that we
really need you know for the next
pandemic for so I think like the the
mimesis can even hyper track
entrepreneurs into all competing to
build the same things and we miss
opportunities and it decreases
Innovation so that's that's where it can
become negative
um and it just it can flip both ways and
as a person as an entrepreneur or
whatever it is that you're doing you
just have to understand when the mimesis
is maybe affecting you in a positive way
and when it's causing you to just look
in this kind of very narrow area because
everybody else is well your book points
out that it tends to lead to conflict uh
and people wanting the same things you
end up having these uh tugs of War
whether that's in an organization or
even society-wide yeah so imagine
turning 10 toddlers loose in a room that
had like more toys than they could ever
need and what happens almost inevitably
they kind of focus in on one toy because
one kid picks it up and then they all
become fascinated with it and pretty
soon they're having a tug of war over it
and they're fighting over it so that's
this kind of amuses reinforces their
desire for the same toy even if there's
a thousand toys in the same room so it
draws or tracks our attention to
something even if that thing is
insignificant right I mean I even go
back to I've got a kind of a riff on why
we became so fascinated with the moon
you know the moon in itself sure there's
some scientific discoveries there but it
was cheese man because it's made of
cheese right no it was Russia right so
and and that we became completely
obsessed with with getting to the moon
and it took on this huge symbolic thing
that was
um more than the moon itself right you
know so these memetic rivalries play out
as children it plays out in geopolitics
it plays out in our careers and we need
to be so it does lead to conflict and it
leads us to do some you know some
frankly some idiotic things we become
obsessed with a rival for instance and
every decision that we're making is sort
of around what that rival is doing I
think this happens in politics all the
time
um you know the right wants to do this
thing so we need to do the opposite
thing and whether that thing makes sense
or not you know it happens both ways so
I think understanding the the role that
memetic desire plays in leading to
rivalries because we're taking other
people as cues or models of Desire if we
don't like them what they want becomes a
negative model for us right this is
called negative imitation people think
of imitation only in the positive sense
like they do X so I do X imitation also
takes a negative form where somebody
else does X so I must then do y just to
differentiate myself from them
yeah you make that point really strongly
in the book and as someone who is the
parent of two boys and also uh had an
older brother myself a lot of the time
it is a negative reaction where you know
you the the older brother is responsible
so you become the the rebel uh not to
say I have any experience with that but
uh there was a subtext in your book that
I enjoyed where it did feel like you
were talking about our politics I'm glad
you picked that up because I didn't
really want to get into it in the book
because I thought it would be an
entirely separate book and maybe that's
the book that I might write next I'm not
sure I don't know if I have it in me to
do that but you know I I mean I wrote it
because I was becoming concerned about
the Rivalry that seems like a zero-sum
game
and I I sort of in my mind having
learned about memetic desire and my
medic rivalry and conflict and the
scapegoating that it eventually leads to
I began to see politics in this as this
highly memetic process with very few
people that were willing to transcend
the zero-sum game and that was a subtext
that was running throughout the entire
book and um I kind of was hoping that
people would make the connections
themselves
foreign
think about the term private citizen
keyword private that's what you want to
be when you go online but unfortunately
not a whole lot we do is kept to
ourselves nowadays it's more like
exposed Who Wants To Be An exposed
citizen not you not me to keep my data
private when I go online I turn to
expressvpn because it's incredibly easy
to use to secure my data and it can do
the same for you it will reroute your
connection and mask your IP address so
basically everyone cannot see what
you're doing and you too can do what you
like in the privacy of your own internet
so if like me you believe that your data
is your business secure yourself with
the number one rated VPN on the market
go to expressvpn.com Yang don't forget
to use my link so you can get three
extra months free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang expressvpn.com Yang to
learn more
foreign
yes because we are all I mean because
you know I mean we all uh bemoan what's
happening now you know what's
interesting Luke is you you had an
alternate explanation for something that
I've seen him been struggling with for
years the word I've used for it is
institutionalization or where it's like
you you're in a particular environment
let's call it a Beltway of DC or
Hollywood
or a university
uh and there is this
dominant culture
and you feel like okay uh everyone else
is doing this so let me go along with it
uh and you have this incredible lack of
going against the grain
um in a lot of these environments where
you can look up in American life and be
like shouldn't someone uh pointed that
one out uh you know or just a random
example popped into my my mind which was
like a Kendall Jenner Pepsi commercial
when she sort of like you know Pepsi
cures racism and then you're like
shouldn't someone in that that room but
like hey guys this is like not the
greatest where where you you have and
the other way of characterizing
institutionalism is group think
um and you had in many ways a deeper
explanation for why we see so much group
think yeah I mean it's group think and
then there's group desire and sometimes
they can be two different things you
know
um you can have people thinking the same
thing and saying that they they think
the same thing but under the surface
um what they're really wanting the same
thing so I mean this happens in Academia
all the time
um you know you just have a very kind of
um hyper focus on these very small
things you know like Freud would call it
the narcissism of very small differences
everybody gets focused on certain things
and yeah I think that it's I mean
they're related and I think that it
causes distortions in reality and our
perception of what people actually think
or what people actually want I mean
their Studies have shown that the things
that people say on social media are like
way more extreme than what they actually
think or what they would tell a buddy
that they're having a beer with in the
backyard so there's there's some
distorted perception and this weird
thing that leads to what a what a social
scientist Elizabeth Noel Newman called
the spiral of Silence where you know
you're sitting around a table people are
having a conversation you don't really
agree
um with everything that's being said but
your you stay silent because you don't
want to like stir the Hornet's Nest and
then they perceive that you agree with
them and then it just sort of spirals
into this thing where nobody actually
knows what anybody thinks nobody knows
what anybody really wants and I think
that's one of the problems we have in
the country today yeah do you think
social media
um makes that a hundred times where I
mean I'm obviously leaving question
where I think social media does make it
100 times worse but I'm I'm um you and I
are old enough to remember a time before
social media
um now it seems like there are these
messages that dominate social media and
then you know like if you raise your
hand to be like hey guys maybe that that
one's like you know not spot on your
your cost benefit is terrible because
you're like oh some people are going to
slag me and be able to get attacked for
doing something rancid I just like Let
it go you know like uh and it'd be I
think I just about everyone listening
this has probably done some version of
that where you you saw some sentiment I
mean
that you were like yeah you know then
like uh like I I I'm gonna like avoid
this particular topic
yeah I mean there's there's definitely I
mean who I don't have the emotional
energy to deal with what happens when
you know I've made the mistake of doing
that in the past and then okay so what
happens if every you know level-headed
person who's like yeah that might be a
little out there I'm gonna say like just
stays quiet because they don't want to
deal with it then the whole Space is
dominated
um by people that never hear that and
this was a problem I think even before
social media I mean you know like high
school before social media for sure but
it I think social media has accelerated
it big time and done some things and
it's sort of like I feel like it's an
out of control train right now and I
haven't given up on it I mean I think
it's possible to build
um better forms of social media but we
can't ignore the human element of it and
mimesis is human and you know we can't
design it away I think there might be
some things that we can do to mitigate
it to decelerate things to you know to
put some breaks on it kind of like you
know the stock market has circuit
breakers or something I think there
might be some ways that we can improve
it a little bit but man fundamentally
this is a human problem in my opinion
and you know we get to the you know
thinking I've been thinking a lot about
AI lately and a lot of these discussions
are sort of even the discussions we're
having about these things are in kind of
a very narrow band where we're just
trying to use more technology to solve a
technological problem and we don't even
have the right people at the table to
have the conversation the way that I
always frame that issue is you know we
have a three City problem
um and we need a three City solution and
in my mind the three cities are Athens
Jerusalem and Silicon Valley Athens is a
city of Reason Jerusalem is a city of
you know religion and tradition Silicon
Valley is technology right and right now
ai is being completely dominated by
maybe Athens but definitely by Silicon
Valley and a lot of the deeply human
questions that we have like the
anthropological questions the ethical
and the moral questions some of those
are going to need to come from you know
maybe what I call Jerusalem as a
metaphor I just think we need to get
everybody at the table they even begin
starting to solve those problems because
it just seems like we need a human a
human solution for this and you know we
just need to kind of I think step back
and be willing to have the Deep
conversations about human nature and
where we're going with this
foreign
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even and I became friends
and thought we should collaborate on a
way to scare the out of people but
also entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andrewyang.com books and there's
a special discount code last election
that you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
yeah you have a very philosophical view
of the world are you spiritual yourself
I am I'm a Catholic and in fact I I you
know I spent several years living in
Rome seriously Discerning the priesthood
wow so the obvious question in
everyone's mind
would be where am I supposed to get my
desires from if not from my social
contexts my peers uh those around me I
would say you have to get them from from
somewhere you know one of the main
points in the book is that we don't
generate our desires out of thin air we
don't generate them out of nothing
um you know this is called this is a
romantic lie
um that I think we we have in a highly
individualistic culture we're social
creatures and our desires are going to
come from other people real fictional
historical right they don't have to be
people on social media they don't even
have to be the people that we interact
with every day I've been deeply
influenced by you know books that I that
are 500 years old you know in history
and models of Desire that I've taken
have drawn on from a bigger universe so
I think maybe it's time to expand our
universe the same thing with when I was
an entrepreneur all of my models all of
my influences this came from this very
insulated world of Las Vegas startups
and it was only when I sort of admitted
other influences in my life like you
know hey maybe I should kind of look
outside of this little bubble that I'm
in
um that my my world started to open up a
little bit so you know I think we need
to be just be intentional about the
kinds of people that are affecting what
it is that we want because normally we
just take it for granted you know we we
think that everything that we want is
the product of our autonomous selves and
so there is some aspect of having the
humility to realize that we are
influenced but we can choose who we're
going to be influenced by I live in the
middle of Washington DC so I've got a
you know I need to be careful about you
know I can't even go to a bar with my
wife without sometimes being negative
influenced by the quality of the
conversations that I hear in every TV
being you know cable news you know 24
hours a day so I have to look outside of
the world that I'm in even today the way
you structure your book uh what was
about kind of the dissent of where our
memetic desires lead you and then you
talk about various techniques and
counter measures uh to examine them more
deeply which I enjoyed and I
did examine my own life a bit I guess it
would be impossible not to now the
entrepreneurial mindset or approach
through uh thick and thin has actually
fueled me for a long time
um and uh my approach to it has been
solve a problem problems like hey like
why aren't there enough entrepreneurs
and I spent six years on that and then
the next was hey uh like why aren't we
responding to Ai and advancing
Technologies uh maybe we should
alleviate poverty and get in front of
this thing before AI comes and displaces
millions of us and then now it's hey our
political system seems deeply broken and
dysfunctional like uh you know let me
work on that now have there been
limitations to this particular approach
uh for sure sometimes I mean being an
entrepreneur uh is profoundly isolating
there's a lot of struggle
um that there is a lot of forced
positivity I was relating to the
beginning of this convo that
so you're you're expecting a parent
um you're you're going to be a dad for
the first time and that's an awesome
time and journey
um I did relate that the first year I
was a father was the toughest year of my
adult life where this entrepreneurial
mindset you have at least for me it
totally failed me
um because you get there and you're like
okay what am I supposed to do like let's
just be can do and uh positive and
optimistic
um and in the context of having a
newborn a lot of it just didn't matter
didn't work a friend of mine said
something to me that stuck with me he
said it's the only time in your life
that just saying okay I'll just work
harder is a total non-answer
and and so it stretched my soul in a
particular direction it led me to see
deficiencies in myself and my family in
a way that I hadn't known but this is a
long-winded way of asking like if people
are on a version of this journey how do
they start to find what you call these
other models of Desire or something that
can be more lasting and sustaining and
might lead to fulfillment growth
personal satisfaction so there's a
difference in the book between thin
desires which are these highly mimetic
shifting desires the things you want
today that you're highly unlikely to
want six months or a year from now and
then thick desires and just to relate
this to what you were describing Andrew
because I I've got a baby on the way and
we were talking a bit before we got
started about what that first year was
like to you
there's something about grounding
yourself in a concrete situation or
concrete sort of objective problem not
to call a baby a problem but there are a
lot of challenges right and it's there's
something incarnational about it that
somehow strips away the thin stuff you
know and and I think having some kind of
groundedness
real problems you know um
are a way to sort of remember what's
important which is another way worse and
then the thin desires will fall away you
well you know I it usually we don't need
to go looking for those things you know
unfortunately yeah yeah you know so you
know my dad has Alzheimer's and you know
that's been an incredibly grounding
thing in my life for the past few years
every time that I'm with him life
becomes very simple
you know and like all of these um you
know crazy ideas that I have some are
good some are probably not so good
um they they sort of
they they recede and I I'm able to focus
on something that's incredibly important
to me I have my our baby's not even born
yet and from what I hear there's really
nothing like the moment the baby is born
but already
I've found some of my thin desires
fading away a bit and I know my wife
would say the same thing so there is I
think grounding oneself in something
real and incarnational is is an
important first step and and then just
kind of reflect and there's there's also
an element of history with thick desires
so you know when I've reflected back on
my whole life going back as early as I
can remember like little league baseball
growing up the things I really cared
about
um and then kind of tracing your own
history of desire and like how what
you've wanted have changed over time
like I wanted to be a doctor I literally
applied to med school because I watched
a lot of ER with my mom and I thought
George Clooney was really cool and then
just sort of seeing the way that
different influences have played out in
my life you know Tony Shea being another
one gives me perspective to see like
patterns and I gained some pattern
recognition and I see you know Luke
usually when you're involved in
something that integrates all of these
things it's something that you do for a
very long time you know it's like
sustainable for you when you are
attracted to something and it feels like
this if it feels like a push in the back
rather than a gentle nice tug at the
front of your shirt there's a difference
between the way that those two things
feel kind of like getting caught up in a
Riptide I now know what those things
feel like and part of why I know what
they feel like is because I've went
through this process of looking back at
my life very carefully and seeing what
happened when I pursue certain past
based on you know whether those
influences were kind of strong memetic
influences or whether there was
something a bit more enduring and
peaceful about my involvement in those
things
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like
five percent of people do the math for a
hundred night free trial you can sleep
on this thing for three months it will
keep you cool don't just take my word
for it my kids seek out this mattress in
the house it's the number one rated
mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine
this mattress will actually make you
happier healthier and more productive
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now
[Music]
Well you certainly have a very like
Serene manner to You Luke uh you know
it's funny you seem Zend out for another
term
um which doesn't surprise me having read
your book
um that you you seem to have reached
like a more elevated plane um than a lot
of folks simply by recognizing what you
call these models of Desire instead of
just being subject to them them are
buffeted by them you're like oh so so
this is something I'm now exposed to uh
which alone can be
um transformative uh it's something that
that you write about there's a quote I
loved that I think a lot of people now
can see uh in our country's politics and
you do have some ideas on how we can get
Beyond this
um so this is a quote by Gerard who who
inspired much of the book human beings
fight not because they are different but
because they are the same and in their
attempts to distinguish themselves have
made themselves into enemy twins human
doubles in reciprocal violence that that
quote would piss a lot of people off I'm
sure yeah because who wants to think
that they may be more like the very
people that they think are the problem
you know no nobody wants to think that
but we we often are more alike I mean in
in World mythology
um there's almost always in almost every
culture there is a story about twins
usually identical twins uh involved in
Conflict you know in the Bible in the
Book of Genesis alone there are five
stories of sibling rivalry and Renee
Gerard looked at this phenomenon you
know like okay they're Miss but why is
there's usually something true right
you're getting at something true in
human nature and the truth that he
thought they were getting at is that
we're kind of terrified of similarity
and we often hate that which
um is kind of like us right
um in in this that plays out in in funny
small ways you know like I don't know
somebody walks into the office with the
same exact haircut that we just got
wearing
the same clothes you know it's like it's
a little weird we don't like that at all
um and we also tend to see in other
people
um sometimes the very things that we
don't like in ourselves and Gerard also
said be careful
be careful who you make your enemies
because you become like them and part of
why you become like them is because
you're so focused on them you imitate
them often in negative ways you know
that they become the biggest influence
on our lives
and I think this is a there's a really
important lesson to be learned here in
U.S politics it causes us to miss out on
a path forward on a way out of the
predicament because we're so focused in
on each other and the image that I like
to use are two people that are you know
I like to think of people standing
shoulder to shoulder looking out at the
future right
um because if they're just standing face
to face in a standoff they can't see the
way out and one small silly little story
I'll never forget when I was a kid and I
I thought of this story after I started
writing this book I remember seeing
these two dogs behind a baseball field
fence near my house and the two dogs
were in a standoff and they both were
kind of barking and wanting to get on
the other side of the fence and they
would look at each other and they were
kind of on the verge of fighting hair
standing knob tails and one of them
would kind of try to walk away to get
away and then you would turn around and
look back and neither one of them could
get away from the other one and all
either one of them needed to do is just
ignore the other one and walk around
fence like 50 yards away but they were
unable to do that because their focus
was was completely on each other and
there's a lesson in there when it comes
to rivalry and conflict and the sort of
the memetic force the centripetal force
that holds us inside of a system or an
institution or a way of thinking and
we're not able to transcend it because
our rival is completely dominating our
mindset yeah you you catalog 15
techniques that you use to try and
transcend those kinds of destructive
Dynamics uh
let's have you share one or two so
people can have a sense as to making
this uh positive and something that they
can recognize then maybe get Beyond sure
there's a couple very simple things you
know one of them that you could do today
if you wanted
and that's you know quite simply naming
who important models in your life have
been and who important models in your
life today might be and actually writing
them down you know there's something
powerful about about naming models of
desire and be careful because models of
Desire are not the same thing as role
models
um models of Desire are people that in
some some sense affect what we want so
they're modeling a desire and not just a
role
um you know my my accountant is a role
model of uh accuracy and organization
for me I have no idea what the guy
desires so he's not he's not a he's not
a model of desire for me so you know put
them all about positive and negative
right on a piece of paper and gain some
clarity you'll probably remember some
tomorrow or the next day and that helps
gain some you know naming things gives
us some power over them or over what
they do to us this is psychology 101
naming your emotions same concept here
and then the other thing is and this one
is a little bit harder the one of the
most positive things ever happened to me
in my life in fact where I learned about
memetic desire and Renee Gerard in the
first place was when I went when I went
on a silent Retreat and
a silent Retreat if even if it's for a
half a day or a day we'll do some pretty
scary things to you in a good way like
things will kind of like bubble up to
the surface that you didn't even know
were there once the noise of technology
and everything recedes
so I think you could start very small
with this you know even even a couple of
hours no technology put everything away
and see what desires bubble up to the
surface because my theory and what I've
experienced in my own life is that the
thick desires that I have the things
that are really important to me are
often just completely crowded out by the
thin mimetic desires the short-term
things that I want and if I spend the
rest of my life just trying like chasing
the thin memetic desires and not even
letting the thick ones bubble up to the
surface I won't even know that they're
there you know it's like leaves that are
covering them up so that's not an easy
thing to do those are just there's 15 in
the book those are those are two small
ones I get into a lot more detail about
how to do those things
um but I think that those are those are
just easy ways to start
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
yeah I I love that you have an entire
newsletter uh dedicated to finding
anti-memetic desires like what do you
want for yourself that's not just
because uh you know like you you saw
someone else want it uh I'm going to
have you close an idea that I thought
was really fun what is freshman a stand
fresh manistan is the word that I give
to a situation like high school or like
being a Freshman anywhere like being a
Freshman in high school or college I
suppose like being a Freshman politician
on the hill too is that I think there's
this phenomenon of
fresh manistan that exists in our world
and I use that term to describe two very
different
um
forms of imitation in the book
the first form of imitation comes when
the models that we're imitating are the
people that are influencing us are kind
of outside of our world you know so for
me growing up you know professional
baseball players I I wanted to play you
know the major league baseball player
um you know people probably people that
I saw on MTV those people are what
Gerard calls external models of Desire
they're outside of a world we're not
going to really come in contact with
them usually
um and they they model desires to us
from from a long ways away
the other world or the other sort of way
that imitation plays out is in an
environment where all of the people
modeling desires to each other are all
in the same place they're all in the
same world and there's no better example
of that for us yeah yeah and far more
common for us right so our families can
be a fresh man of stand obviously school
can be one and imitation gets a lot more
tricky in that situation because we're
all aware of each other and we can act
we can actually be doubly imitating each
other we can be reinforcing desires to
one another this is how you know Trends
and and fashionable ideas start our
ideas go in in fashion and out of
fashion when we're in that kind of
environment and the difference between
the two is that in a fresh manistan kind
of environment it's often very hard to
know like who's influencing who who was
the first mover here and it causes a
loss of differentiation if people aren't
aware that that's happening to them so I
I think that social media is uh plunging
our world into one giant fresh Mana
stand because we're all kind of the same
on social media on Twitter everybody's
got the same limits to their profile the
same amount of characters and this sort
of forces a degree of similarity that I
don't think is healthy fresh manistan is
the enemy in many ways I you know I
remember showing up for college as a
freshman and it certainly seemed like uh
every
uh social interaction was like the most
important thing in the world
now we look back at it and be like oh
that that that uh you know that young
dumb version of me uh didn't you know
someday you were gonna run for president
anyway
which I definitely do not know at that
point well Luke uh you know um I I see
you as an entrepreneurial philosopher uh
which is a very rare combination and
something we need a lot more of in the
world and I think your book actually has
a ton of insight for helping us move
beyond our current dysfunctional brand
of politics uh I highly recommend people
check it out wanting the power of
memetic desire in everyday life it'll
make you think about uh what you want
and why if someone wants to keep up with
you Luke uh how can they best do so
they can I write a Weekly Newsletter
called the anti-memetic newsletter and
you can find that on
read.lukeburges.com fantastic Luke keep
up the awesome work and uh congrats in
advance you're going to make a
tremendous dad oh thanks so much Andrew
it's been a pleasure
[Music]
foreign